i think greg frazier cinematography in
this is breathtaking
it's like it's so gorgeous that it does
it doesn't make sense for both of you
it really is amazing for both of you
could you talk a little bit about
working with him and perhaps one of the
more challenging shots that you needed
to pull off
matt
wrote this incredible script and put
together a beautiful team including greg
at the helm and and and an important
part of any
cinematographer's work is also the
production designer and the costume
designers work because that's the image
they're photographing stepping onto this
set
was a really good feeling the back lot
that we had was incredible what greg did
was incredible james chandler production
designer yeah and matt's
conception you were in the hands of a
filmmaker him and greg together
so it was a really uh beautiful space to
go to work i mean for me one of my
favorite
memories was the the the diner scene all
night on that back lot
the way it looked you know i i saw on
the monitor and
the
incredible camera mechanism they used to
do the coffee uh cup shot um
just incredible to to to get that's one
of the few moments where i was going
okay i'm i'm i'm impressed uh you know
um and this is awesome yeah i was really
taken by greg's work and and
it was really clear to me and i just
said it like just consciously to myself
a few times on set man this guy is a
painter i mean he really does paint with
light and
i would look at in fact the diner scene
we shot the scene i was looking at the
monitor and we were trying to
get this relationship of rob and i
outside the diner and i looked at the
monitor and i'm like oh my god dude all
you need to do is stand right there and
it's all said
greg
uses shadow and light but these these
just brush strokes of color oranges here
these kind of
pinks there in a way that and it's
consistent in a way
that's just so beautiful
and and so informative of tone
and mood and does so much work for us as
actors and i literally said to myself
just stand there don't do anything and
let his work speak
uh he's he's really really brilliant
a lot of people there's a lot of people
unfortunately who think like the
superhero genre um it's like a lot of
the same movie you know like they're
tired of the genre i would argue that
this movie is a perfect reason
of what can be done in terms of the
filmmaking it's a it's a [ __ ] amazing
movie that just happens to star batman
you know it's an artistic movie can you
sort of talk about that aspect of this
film
i feel so lucky
to be a part of it for that reason
because i think it gives the audience
what it what it what it wants and what
it needs and what batman should while
i mean i think it's an immersive piece
of cinema and i am so impressed by what
matt has done and it really his
conception of this was full uh and and
uh
so as an audience member i it's not like
that fun to watch yourself but i
loved watching this movie because of
what matt did that opening
fear sequence on the streets i mean it's
incredible the construction what the
camera is doing what the lighting is
doing as you mentioned like all the
elements the sound and the score it's
it's an immersive film i really hope i i
know we're all saying this but this is a
movie to see in a theater like you need
to give yourself over to this experience
uh and so um i agree that i think this
makes a a really strong case uh that
this this is a real film yeah i'm
excited for audiences particularly
younger audiences to take in this film
because you know obviously you know
there's a lot of comic book films out
there and i think at times ken relied on
the bells and whistles uh a bit much and
i think
for younger audiences particularly who
have grown up with that that this film
has you know that kinetic energy and you
know the fantastical elements but it's
plot driven it's emotional it's
psychological it's um it's it's
beautiful it's well considered in a way
that i think is going to open
younger eyes particularly to things that
they maybe hadn't experienced before in
theaters with a gen with a film like
this of this genre so i'm excited for
all uh folks to see it but particularly
the younger younger folks in the
audiences
and that note i gotta go congrats for
real you both did such a great job thank
you thanks
you